[Music]
hopefully many of us are back out on the
road taking road trips while the fun of
traveling is visiting new places there
are areas you might want to avoid crime
and place is a unique iphone app that
instantly provides you with personal and
property crime rates for any location
current rates based on fbi data if you
are traveling for business or for fun
start with a trip to crimeanplace.com
for your free download of this helpful
app
stay aware stay safe travel with crime
in place
that's a good one man that is a good one
everybody should be using crime in place
anywhere you're going excuse me this is
going to be safe man man i actually just
saw a deal i think yesterday the fbi put
out or something like that that
homicides were up 30 percent
uh in 2020 compared to 2019 so yeah the
highest on record that since they've
ever been tracking those type of things
so be careful an app be careful be aware
of your surroundings but an app like
crime and place will kind of help you
out wherever you're going you know
you want to go to this mall or not this
mall that type of deal yeah of course
malls are one of those uh you have a
good mom and a bad mom that is very true
um anyways so
howard doss hey john lurkin today we
have got uh a guest here on cocktails
and cocktails with us
that
i
quasi worked with i guess i'd say for a
few years while doing live pd now i
remember you doing that show
you know and part of that show many many
beneficial things to it but one of the
things on it were uh you know there were
certain officers on the show
that just kind of stood out they were
just people that were doing their job
for whatever reason
anything from tattoos the way they talk
to people how busy they were whether or
not they like red boots or not whether
or not they write likes yes
that type of stuff you know if they had
um you know people love the canines you
know all the the viewers really
resonated with those with the canine
but we had a few female officers on the
show that really stood out and one of
them is miss zendejas
who was known as the the steel bun i
think or something to that effect that
he didn't clarify for us but she wore
this big bun in her hair that never
moved no matter what she we're not
talking a hamburger but like it looked
like it was fake and pinned in there not
a hamburger bun now her she's got this
long very dark mane of hair and so it
was always pinned up a lot like mine
exactly like yours
so miss and dejas how are you today good
good
it's a pleasure
hey
we we we really like to do one thing
when we have this conversation we kind
of like to keep it casual best way to
usually keep it casual is have some
drinks so big fan of drinks so would you
pick tonight for us to drink
pick some uh
red wine oh we haven't had red wine we
haven't
we have had several different uh ladies
females here on the show and you are the
first one that picked red wine
and this will kind of tie into a little
bit later in our story of what's going
on in your life now so the bottle that
we have selected uh it's a red blend
it's from california it's a local one it
is it's a it's a red one i think
everybody's gonna get a kick out of this
one we're gonna enjoy drinking it yeah
it's good i look forward to tasting it
it is called menage a trois
and that is the uh red wine we'll be
drinking tonight if you're okay with it
yeah you know there's three of us
talking so it just kind of fit yeah
absolutely kind of fits
it's definitely fitting
thank you you gave me the jesus pour
you like more yeah i mean this is like
what you get at communion
we have these very high classes i'm
going to show you our body of christ yes
i have some
we we didn't have any wine glasses so i
bought some at that or
these aren't real these are these are
plastic
all right so let's jump into this but
first cheers to you cheers thank you so
much for watching
okay for uh our listeners out there if
you would pronounce your first and last
name please
andrea is in dalhouse
and deos and let's clarify something i
think everybody thought because you were
working in el paso and your name they
made the assumption one that i think you
spoke spanish to that you were have
hispanic
heritage and clarify that as well
okay so long ago
i was married and um my husband was
hispanic he was from southern california
um i never changed my last name once we
divorced because i was in the military
so if you're familiar everything has
your name sewn on it
no i figured you know i'm still young
i'll remarry again
no never happened here i am 36 i still
have his name
but it did benefit me um living in el
paso it kind of gave me a little pass
even though i didn't know a lot of
spanish a little street cred what was
your maiden name
it was it's fuller fully that's not
spanish that's definitely
very much
english irish they didn't think he they
didn't think you were a gringa is it
gringa green gringos right i honestly
don't even know i don't know about that
at all all right so tell us how how did
you get into i mean you came from
southern california with a dude and you
ended up in el paso how'd you end up
being a police officer we always start
with that because
it's kind of a serendipitous road most
people take it to law enforcement we
like hearing it
well always wanted to be a police
officer
even when i was you know a kid i kind of
grew up in that kind of uh
family setting
so i wasn't old enough um
joined the military
almost 10 years
and ended up in el paso texas at fort
bliss and
had a spinal injury
so i got medically retired and then
ended up staying
and applied for the police department
like a year after
about a year after i got out
and i was there for the last seven years
what did you do in the military well
okay first off what branch
army okay gotcha and then what they have
you doing in there besides getting
spinal injuries
so i was um
well back in the well years ago was
called nbc okay so it's like a nuclear
nuclear biological chemical specialist
oh
we couldn't do that no
what did you do what'd you do in the nbc
um well we did everyone else's job
yeah so we trained a lot you know with
our job and such but um ended up pretty
much doing everyone else's job
and um we ran like the uh
the cs chamber
for everyone what's this yeah
oh okay yeah part of the training all
right yeah
part of the training we don't we the
only guest that we have to deal with
nursing is something that everybody
deals with so yeah
totally different
dirty people with stinky booties so
let's get a guess we did
andrea when you applied for the police
department um you know el paso is a big
department that's a big agency
and
getting on there do you have any
difficulty getting on or
your your military background kind of
give you a you know leg up an easy easy
way in the academy was no big deal that
type of deal
yeah i mean um well i was coming
straight out of or straight from active
duty so i do think of course that
probably gave me a
little bit of upper hand
um it was pretty simple
um
just went for it and it worked out
academy was fine
like like i said i did have the spinal
injury and uh i do have a fusion so i
had to be very careful but
it was fine
it was fine
so when you got out did they put you
like i mean some uh okay el paso is a
big department how big is it what do you
mean big like eight hundred like telstra
is a bigger thing it's like twelve
hundred when i left oh
they're a little bit bigger than this
yeah um
do they have you go straight into patrol
they have you go in the jails with a
heavy day
no since we were city police um we went
straight to patrol straight to the
streets
do they
like cut you loose on your own do they
give you a mentor how does that work
um so i had a an fto field training
officer for a year
after the academy i did the academy i
think about eight months
and then um i had an fto for
a year after that well
a lot of our um listeners of the podcast
and we have a lot of those can't see
this i mean you can't see it on youtube
if you want to watch it but um
being a woman you're always kind of put
in you're always kind of underestimated
right so
being a
a woman that's obviously a woman
did you get a lot of pushback when you
initially got on the streets they test
you a lot
no not really um i just treat
however people need to be treated you
know and usually it's uh respected
and you just gotta
you know stand firm with who you are and
once they see that you're not playing
then you usually don't have a problem
yeah you know and
from my own experience you know i've
obviously worked around a lot of females
i've supervised females and you know
things like that throughout the years
bad guys you know on the street
you know they're not trying to
talk crazy to some um
you know a smaller male officer or you
know try to pick on a female they're not
because you know they're all about
street cred and this type of thing and
so they want to try to go at you know
the tougher looking cops and
um i mean just as she you know andrea
was saying though
whether you're a female a rookie an
experienced officer a big muscular guy
out there it's all about how you're
going to talk to people anyways and
that's going to really dictate
how pretty much most of your contacts go
and that's kind of what i think all the
fans the viewers of live pd
really loved about you on there
was how you spoke with everybody i mean
that that was that's
why you were such a favorite on there
because of how calm no matter what the
call was whatever it was you went to on
how you spoke with people
some of these calls what kind of stuck
out i mean what's a good example of how
she was speaking to people you got one
for us
oh
[Music]
well basically well first of all i spent
almost 10 years in the army so that
taught me lots of patience
whether i wanted it or not right um
but it goes back to how i was raised you
know i was raised to respect people
regardless you know it doesn't matter
who you are um
so
nine times out of ten
i had no problems with people zero
almost
gotcha well so you were on the force for
seven years
and
there's kind of a story about you
leaving right you want to well we we got
we got time to get to that i know you're
trying to get to the good juicy stuff
but you know
yeah well the people you know
the listeners here she was a literally a
big part of live pd okay and so i think
a lot of people are going to have
questions just asking uh how did you get
selected you know from your department
to be part of that because a lot of
people think that the the show the
networks the producers pick who's on the
show and they don't they have nothing to
do with that really so obviously you had
to
um you know whether stand out to
somebody on your department a supervisor
there was a reason why you were picked
can you talk about that
sure so
absolutely nobody wanted to be on
national television
i had other plans for my career i was
actually
really good at narcotics not doing them
but
getting them and that's kind of where i
wanted my career to go
um
so when the show came to town um
my lieutenant asked me
to do him a favor and just you know ride
with the camera crew one time and i'm
like but lt
you know what i'm trying to do with my
career and so and i knew once i go on
television especially around there
everybody watches it right so
pretty much knew that those dreams were
going to be flushed down the toilet at
that point
um
i did it one time and the producer came
back and she just kept asking me again
and again and we kind of built this
bond and they became like my family and
i you know started enjoying it i started
um
seeing what a big impact it was having
on everyone
and i think it was a pretty crucial time
for us as law enforcement officers um
to to show the real us like to show the
human aspect because that's not how
we're shown obviously
and um it just it was just a huge impact
on
on everybody so it kind of changed
it changed my way of
uh how i
decided to handle my career
um but the the narcotics thing was
definitely out of the question at that
point you couldn't go incognito anymore
huh you had already been sprung they
knew you were a cop they didn't even
have to ask
well you know when you're
on patrol i mean you wore glasses
and had your hair up in the bun so does
everybody recognize you with your hair
down i mean obviously right now you're
not wearing glasses so when you're out
and about in public
um everybody still recognize you oh yeah
it's um especially el paso it was not a
day went by if i left my house it was it
was usually
i would random i would run into like
three or four people at least but
everybody was friendly i assume yes
absolutely respectful
and it's like it goes back to all how
you treat people that's it and yeah
you're perceived but it takes a little
while to get used to that because you
know when you're in uniform you're used
to people paying attention to you
looking at you whether you're in a
restaurant or driving your car people
turn and look at you but
when you're in plain clothes off duty
and people recognize you and want to
come up and talk to you and you know
those type of things i mean for for a
while there it's it's different isn't it
it's very different especially i have
two small smaller children
so being approached out in public
or at stores or restaurants or you know
you don't you don't know what people's
intentions are they may be good or they
may not
um
and
thankfully all mine were good um and you
know i had a couple instances where my
children were they were put in harm's
way and that contributed to my decision
to leave as well
so but i mean it's taking the good with
the bad and you know always protecting
yourself no matter what
yeah absolutely so during your seven
years there is there a
you know a particular call or incident
um you know throughout your career
that's really stood out to you when you
look back and you kind of go wow or man
i was lucky or man i was glad i was a
part of that
um
there's there's a few but
um i'll give you this one
it was the end of the night i was
working a graveyard shift it was the end
of the night
me and my partner were downloading early
early in the morning like five or six
o'clock in the morning meaning putting
our
equipment into our cars in a
gated
parking lot
um
my partner was setting a front seat i
was in the back at the trunk taking my
stuff out and i just hear these shots
and then i hear them impact around me
and i'm like oh shit
like somebody is shooting at us
at you guys yeah yes
so um it was crazy because i looked and
as soon as i looked at the roadway it's
like my mind took like a snapshot
of the vehicle and like the taillights
and everything
and um which is crazy i've never really
experienced that before
and so
we jumped in the car i jumped in the car
i called out let you know dispatch know
what was going on
and we pursued them and we got them
they tried to lose us and uh we actually
got him it was a bunch of teenagers and
we were able to recover
uh some weapons and stuff so
um it was pretty good
i'm sorry why'd they say they were
shooting at you just they want to shoot
it through the police
yeah
damn
doing our normal routine downloading our
equipment at the end of the shift and
they knew that that was a parking lot
for law enforcement
so during the pursuit did they you know
were they ballsy enough to fire any
rounds during the pursuit or not um they
i guess they thought that we lost them
but like i said i remembered the um
i remember the taillights and i seen
them turn down a road and i'm like oh
hell no you're not getting away from me
so they were just basically little
cowards that try to ambush you guys
but then when you brought the battle or
went after them they just kind of it was
it was pitched up i'll put it that way
we'll be in a border town el paso is a
border town um and i've been through el
paso quite a bit what kind of i mean you
hear about a bunch of smuggling
operations things being thrown across
uh border security that kind of stuff
did you have to mess with me after that
all the time
all the time
um a big thing before i left um it was
weekly
that we were getting like welfare checks
um called in by like neighbors
and we would get there and we would meet
with the you know the person who called
and they would tell us oh our neighbors
are or you know they don't live in the
house or
[Music]
they passed away and no one's supposed
to be in the house right
so
but they would see people in the house
uh so we would go and investigate and
nine times out of ten it was a human uh
stash house
and those were we found those on a
weekly basis
you know and that was just my shift i'm
sure there was
plenty other ones on the other ships
well explain to us what kind of house
that was it you call this
snack
a human stash house so once they're
smuggled
across the border they stash these
people
they stash these people in um in random
houses
and wait for the next transport to come
and take them i guess whatever else
right they just say here we have an
empty house let's put some people in
here pretty much it's it's absolutely
nuts
damn
well um you are no longer in law
enforcement
um that career came to a closure earlier
this year this summer
and i think at the end of july if i
remember correctly
um you have uh
moved on and you've got another little
uh a gig going
um but during
the time your transition as you were
phasing out your law enforcement career
uh is kind of when you started this
other one is that correct
that's correct
and what exactly are you doing now
these days
missing um
so
about a month out
i dropped my
resignation paperwork
and basically gave them my last day
which was july 31st and that was going
to be it
um
one of those weekends i went to the
beach with uh my best friend
we're sitting there one morning while
the sun's coming up
and we're talking
and um
it was always a running joke with my
partners right because you know joking
about you know cop pay and we don't make
what we hear what we should or whatever
that's the truth
and um so we would always we would
always joke about starting and only fans
you know okay so people out there that
don't know and i'm i'm sure my mom's
listening and she has no idea what holy
fans is so can you kind of tell people
in a
i'm gonna say nutshell but it's a bad
choice of words what olympians is
okay
so only fans is a paid like a
subscription site where um it's
primarily used for adult entertainment
and that could be
that could be it could be used for
anything but it's primarily uh primarily
used for uh porn or
you know
usually just porn
i don't have any other ones
we have a woman in town who is an author
and she writes racybooks and she has an
only fans account and she'll read
chapters out of her books on there
that's all she does is
read from her books and she's got like
10 of them or so so yeah there's amazing
well but she's reading about people
having sex right
yeah i mean she's not reading like abe
lincoln's
you know scores and seven
take my years off take a look at these
dr seuss
no yes i would not could not ride in a
boat no no yes i mean nobody's teaching
you how to fix sinks i mean maybe
i've seen those videos the plumber shows
up
there's only one way it could be paid
for
so
anyways so now we know what only fans is
okay so you um you do so prior to
leaving the department you turn in your
paperwork um you're on the beach you're
with your friend
the idea of only fans comes back up and
then what happens
um i'm like well shit like i only have a
month left um what's what's really
what's what's it gonna hurt you know i
wasn't going fully nude i wasn't doing
porn um i wasn't in uniform
[Laughter]
um despite
you know uh requests no it's not in
uniform um
so i'm like eh okay
so i started it actually that morning
and um
and it's funny
i used to send these pictures to people
for free
howard has quite a collection of them
this is quite empowering to women too
i'm all for this shit i mean i think
this is great i mean this is
this is
anybody who thinks this is bad this is
femininity at its finest and being a
feminist is fine
if anybody is out there is going to talk
hate on what she's doing just mind your
own damn business and that's okay that's
okay they can talk all they want right
i welcome that because it just drives me
to do more
it's been super successful so um for
something that i just joked around about
um
i mean
i've
i've done very well well the funny thing
is is you said i just woke up in the
morning here i go i mean you're
obviously you're treating like a job i
mean
it's not like you're sleeping in until
four in the afternoon it's like okay
time to do some work but i can imagine
that this wasn't well accepted by after
you resigned that you started this
it was not
yeah how the department uh
how did they react
so
um like i said i started it actually may
31st
and my resignation date is july 31st so
exactly a month
um
and
almost immediately
maybe a weekend maybe two weeks in
um i got an email
telling me to report to ia this date
this time you know to meet with an
investigator and i is
internal affairs that's the principal's
office you guys talk cop stuff i can go
okay
this is the principal police show i have
i watched that one that live pd man they
never said internal affairs on there so
you didn't watch it
so i already kind of had an idea i had
an idea of probably what it was about
but it was fine because i didn't feel
like i was doing anything wrong
so i get there um
sit down and they tell me they come in
the room they tell me um well you're
under criminal investigation
i'm like criminal investigation
i've never done anything well
crazy in my life like you know to be
under criminal investigation
and i'm like well what for
and um they proceeded to tell me that i
was under criminal investigation for
prostitution
so this isn't like administrative
investigation like violation policies
this is something criminal in nature
like the violation of a state statute a
state law
that's right so what happened
um they
the special investigative unit
or special investigations unit um i
guess they picked up on my social media
they always watched my social media
pretty closely anyway i knew that you
know it was no big deal
um
so
they um they started a criminal
investigation on prostitution i guess
because i was making money they thought
i was meeting with people for whatever
um
and when they found out
that that was not the case they passed
it on to internal affairs the
principal's office to
do further
uh discipline for policy violation hey
well let's go back for a second so they
monitor social media like i moderate my
teenager social media like that oh yeah
and it was did they ever come to you and
go uh we think you should take this post
down we didn't like this one or can you
change no i never cared oh i got you
they asked you to do that
no no i had actually had no idea i was
under any kind of investigation because
um i was what i was doing so so only
fans is very interactive
so people make money off of you know
talking to people and and that's why
it's different from like
pornhub which is a free porn site right
never heard of it i'm sure you haven't
but
it's a little bit different because it's
very interesting
howard get that pen and paper
what was the name of this again horn hub
it's h-o-r-n-hub
no hey sean has a very interesting story
to tell right now and this is very funny
and this is very applicable to this sean
got his uh uh his credit card stolen
and he had all these charges on there so
he called the credit card company and
said hey i don't have these charges on
here i got my credit card stolen and uh
the lady goes well we have like 99
dollars here 99 here
and you go ahead and tell us the story
yeah so one of them was uh it was a
charge for like 1999 and i did not
recognize the name on my my bill and so
i called the number associated with that
charge and the people answer and i'm
like hey i've got this charge for 19.99
on my credit card trying to figure out
what it is and they said yeah we're
whatever the name of their company is
but we're an online billing service for
porn sites and so it was a woman that
answered and i said who the hell pays
for porn i'm like it's free and she
didn't even laugh i mean i thought it
was hilarious but i've heard it i've
heard it's free i've heard it's free and
but anyways yeah so that was just uh
that was recent
within the past year so somebody is out
there actually paying for porn but
anyway so only fans like you said
subscription service and then i think
you guys you pay to talk to people to
make personal videos for them
um
and i mean you can even do like live
deals where people make i guess
donations things of that nature there's
several different ways you can generate
revenue with your own site correct
absolutely yes
and it does very well i mean i think you
know i mean not to get into all your
finances but you have
done very well in a short amount of time
compared to the money you were making as
a police officer
yes
i hadn't known that i would have done it
a long time ago
sean and i make videos and we don't make
that kind of money then howard howard
gets pretty close to making some of them
i have breakaway pants from time to time
but but so internal affairs so they when
they do have you in there though
um
they
show you some messages between yourself
and somebody
that
at least posing as a potential
client customer or whatever correct yes
um
so they opened up the computer showed me
the folder and because i had to provide
a statement um on my behalf of course
well before you did you go in there with
a representative
that time i
did i think i did that time okay
leading like they were they were picking
little things here and there up until
the time i left so uh you know when i
did start seeing the pattern i did start
bringing um a rep with me representing
how to say any of our police officers
police officers out there listening i'm
not saying every single time you go to
ia take somebody with you but if there's
a potential criminal investigation take
either an attorney or a rep from your
lodge with you pro tip
yes
okay sorry go ahead
so i'm looking at these uh screenshots
of these messages that they have and
it's a um
it's a private conversation between me
and one of the followers on the site
and the conversation stood out in my
mind because i remember this person
being very rude and
almost never anyone is rude yeah they're
like
dirty and you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but they're never rude they're never
disrespectful to that point um this
person was trying to buy me um
and they kept on and on
and so that's why it kind of stood out
um
now just to clear things up uh too
i i was i was never fully nude didn't do
porn or anything like that
um so it's kind of like a huge teasing
site if you will um
because i have a very mixture a very
mixed
audience of fans and some people might
not be ready
for some of those things
so
so i keep it you know i try to keep it
at a happy medium um
but
yeah so so it stood out right and i'm
like whoa i'm like how the hell did you
guys get these messages because these
are private mm-hmm
this is like me texting one of my
friends
you know and talking back and forth um
i never met the guy
um but it did it stuck out on my mind
and i'm like holy cow like this has to
be a cop
and the supervisor was like well yeah
it's a criminal investigator and i'm
like what
what's that crap man
i feel like it is
so um you know time goes on and so i
remember the conversation so i find the
user
and i kind of keep my eye on them
because they would continue they didn't
know that i knew who they were
so i ia did not communicate with the
criminal investigation people hey she
knows who this is
uh yeah okay hey did you uh did you fuck
with him a little bit i did
a bitch and i made some money off the
city of el paso
all right you gotta tell this how please
tell us
okay so um
they continued you know they continued
hey um meet me here i'll be in el paso
at this time meet me seventeen hundred
dollars two thousand dollars i'm like
dude like first of all i'm just selling
my selfies
and some booty and some booty shots okay
like i ain't trying to meet nobody
and so i told him this over and over
and um but they kept they kept they were
they were persistent and um so i was
like all right i like it
i made a video a personalized video for
that account and i was in lingerie and
you know had my hair up glasses
took it all down threw it all around
and got up onto the camera and i just
flipped them off and they paid for it
so
so the thing is like
i can make pictures and videos and i can
also attach a price tag so you have to
pay before you view it right
so how much how much how much you get
them for
i put 100 price tag on that oh good for
you
so that and i'm just
working on the police department dealing
with department money you used to buy
dope to pay informants and things like
this you have to turn in a receipt well
you have like this buy sheet that you
have to turn in every time because every
dollar has to be accounted for do you
turn in like a copy a link to the video
as well
why are we pushing it off why are we
paying the office for this money
exactly yeah we just got the officer
leaving our department we're giving her
extra money okay
so how did this end up did they kind of
go all right yeah you're
you're fine everything's good
no um i had to go through a whole
formal proceeding with it
uh very embarrassing
um because what i do is private right
unless you pay for it not everybody can
see it right
right so what they did um with the whole
investigation they tried to get me on
like 10 or 12 policy violations
nothing stuck because they didn't have
anything
um but it had to go to
what's called a discipline review board
which is used for like serious shit like
i don't know shootings and excessive use
of force and stuff like that right not
oh
officer here that's leaving the
department she's not only fans
generally not used for that um
so anyway
i was gonna be out of town i actually
flew to the virgin islands that week and
they're like oh no you need to be here
for this for this board because it's
like
20 or 30 board members and it consists
of civilians and
high-ranking
uh officers from my department chiefs
sergeants lieutenants you know and
civilians from my community
right
so is it criminal or is this just an
internal thing in order to take it
criminal
no so the criminal thing was already
over okay so they they determined okay
there's no criminal element here um
there's no criminal offense um because i
wasn't they were trying what they were
trying to do is they were trying to set
me up they were trying to debate me yeah
they were trying to do that they thought
i was hungry for money and they thought
that i would take the bait and it had i
took the bait right and met this person
they would arrested me on the spot for
prostitution
so that's what they were trying to do
but i mean i don't do that so it wasn't
ever a question
um so
the board came up i was on vacation
right i was in the virgin islands
sipping on a freaking margarita looking
at the sunset somewhere
coming up with another good idea on the
beach yes
absolutely thank you so great ideas are
born yes um
so
they called me and they're like well
three of the policy violations stuck um
so you're going to be disciplined for um
discredit to the to the department
social media violation
and
i don't know some other bullshit
umbrella policy violation they could
come up with
and so i bought 16 hours which means
they took 16 hours of my vacation before
i left
oh to go back to the discipline review
board i had submitted
for
a um
uh
personal records
uh
i had paid to you know get my personal
records like your hr your file right
yeah well from the city like that and
that would involve any kind of accident
any kind of ticket anything that had you
know that i was involved in right um and
so i
got that
and it was an entire powerpoint about
this thing
of me
um my life pd time
uh my only fans and they were trying to
link everything together
and they you know i answered like 49
questions for this statement that they
had me right it was it was embarrassing
and it was um it was really a like a
punch in the face honestly and then once
everything was said and done
i did leave on honorable terms
um
but i was treated like an outsider
that sucks well hey the thing that
sticks out to me is
this you this isn't why are they jacking
with you don't they have better stuff to
do i mean
you got you got 1200 different officers
and you're going to go after the one
that's sending selfies and getting a
little cash for it this seemed like that
yeah i mean it seems like you had some
haters in there and they were just
trying to stick stuff to you which is
well that's the worst guy now i'm going
to be
devil's advocate here
being a supervisor for the last 16 years
of my career there are policies of just
like the things she was talking about
discredit to the department we have one
that's called like conduct unbecoming of
an officer and it doesn't have like a
flat out definition it's basically is
there something you do that is conduct
i'm becoming right and so if you've got
staff uh upper management people they
you know they view their department or
the the city as an entity is does this
look bad on us
and so but i see that she's already quit
well she was still in her apartment at
the time i got you but she was on her
way out it's not like she was she had
already decided i mean some hey i know
places that give you two weeks notice
and they say well you can let me ask you
this you as a nurse if you were doing
stuff like that would your facility holy
shit you should see tick tock no i'm
just saying no no i'm dead serious if
you were doing an only fan stripping
down doing stuff would your nursing
profession or who your employer is frown
down on it
hmm
maybe we're currently in a nursing
school
so what i'm saying i'm just i really do
honestly yeah i'm just
it's just i i know
um
you know obviously not an act of
prostitution happened
nothing criminal that has happened but
there are policies that just go hey this
falls outside of what we look for at in
an employee right and then you can
either be disciplined or even terminated
but
you know she was on her on her way out
the door anyway so
um that ends up getting wrapped up you
end up leaving the department
um you've actually left the city of el
paso now um you have moved to another
place so what is going on in life for
you now
now um i
moved my
my children me and my kids my dogs uh we
moved to the beach
in wilmington north carolina
it's beautiful out here we just you know
we're closer to family
um
this
side gig
has really it's really demanding
actually um
so it's you know it is like i hate to
say it because it's so silly but it is
like a full-time job um so i just do
what i got to do on there i'm going to
school um hopefully about to buy my
first rental property
um
and start into real estate and just keep
it going uh there's a couple business
things that i'm looking at
and um also
um possibly
a non-profit for
um
police officers and veterans who maybe
are suffering from mental some kind of
mental distress that are afraid to go to
their command for help
because
that's kind of like there's a rule
there's a stigma on that um because
we're afraid that we won't be able to
feed our families if we say the wrong
thing right so
um there's a there's a few things in the
works so i'm staying super busy i'm
super motivated about it i want to help
our guys out
absolutely i need to get you connected
with a good personal friend of mine that
i hope to have here on the podcast a guy
by the name of corey scott
uh was on the department um actually
left the department got his master's
degree in counseling and that's what he
is actually doing now is helping
veterans and law enforcement officers
you know through the the parts of life
that come along with this job that the
mental health aspect of it that's
exactly what he's doing
we need it now more than ever yeah so
we've only got a few more minutes uh
left before we have to wrap this up um
we got about four or five for all of our
listeners out here that want to
uh be very personal with you
um how can they find you
well um
i can i will post a link usually in my
instagram a couple times a week but um
it's www.onlyfans.com
forward slash
u
one four seven
one four six
one nine eight holy cow
all right look what's your instagram
they can go to that and find it
instagram's super easy to find i'm all
over that place
and what is your instagram
it's uh
kristen.zendejas.3
is that with a c or k
that's with a k all right just had to
ask for people hey i have a question to
ask too
are we being charged for this
do we over 15
i didn't see your boobies and you're not
sending me any pics so i think
well if you go to our instagram and look
under there you can see
you should charge for that you know that
right um
nice shit probably
only hands i think people pay to have
him put it but his shirt on
and that's probably true but once again
for all of our listeners out here so now
you understand why we have selected
manager
as our wine selection for our red blend
or 2019 california wine tonight luscious
it is it's good
it's good well let me ask you this
before we let you get out of here do you
miss law enforcement or is it kind of
like all right i've done you know i've
done my done my military thing i've done
the police thing you know you have spent
looks like 17 years
serving
wearing the uniform and you're you know
you've done your time you're glad you've
moved on and doing other things in life
so i'm super glad i moved on that's a
chapter closed um i don't regret it at
all i i will always miss the job and my
guys
that was the biggest they were my family
you know
we were we rode together we did whatever
you know just to whatever we had to do
to get through the night alive and so i
have a very strong attachment to that
um
as far as going ever thinking about it
again probably not
um but it was the greatest job in the
world it really was serving the
community that i lived in
absolutely well i'm glad that i was uh
fortunate as well as the two million
people that tuned into live pd they got
to see you out there so
you were a a fan favorite for sure i
know that people loved you and uh glad i
got to see you work and thank you for
being on the podcast we wish you the
absolute best in what you're doing yes
ma'am thank you
cheers
you